team n'avait retenu que christophe priou
merci monsieur le président le 26 juin
prochain
les électrices et électeurs de loire
atlantique auront à se prononcer sur
l'avenir du projet d'aéroport du grand
ouest à notre dame des landes
cette consultation décidée par le prion
la république aura lieu alors même que
cette question a déjà été tranchée par
la démocratie représentative et la
justice et que la zad zone de non droit
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
nantes rennes ces deux villes étant
victime actuellement de violences
urbaines inadmissible
cette zone de non droit n'a jamais été
vaincus évacués bafouant ainsi l'acte iv
l'autorité républicaine
il ya un mois un rapport comment
recommandé par madame la ministre de
l'environnement ségolène royal valider
la pertinence du transfert tout en
remettant en cause les p2pistes prévu
seulement une nouvelle fois le doute
un scénario à une piste entraînerait de
fait le lancement d'une nouvelle longue
procédure en vue d'une déclaration
d'utilité publique avec des recours
multiples le projet nition livré sans
doute pas l aéroport du grand ouest
compléterait alors la longue litanie des
projets bloqués aux intérêts par madame
la ministre de l'environnement notamment
en région pays de la loire dire oui aux
transferts reviendrait alors à dire non
à l'aéroport
les électeurs qui devront s'exprimer
dans quelques semaines doivent avoir une
connaissance claire de la conséquence de
leur vote sur l'avenir de l'aéroport
certes c'est pourquoi seul le projet de
piste validé par la justice et
contribuant à réduire les nuisances
sonores peut être sommé la consultation
monsieur le premier ministre le scénario
à deux pistes sera-t-il clairement
évoquée dans le document de la
commission nationale du débat public
monsieur le premier ministre il vous
appartient à présent d'affirmer que la
consultation du 26 juin prochain portera
clairement sur le transfert d'un
aéroport à deux pistes un autre dame des
landes et que si le oui l'emporté c'est
bien ce projet qui sera lancé par votre
gouvernement
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
président monsieur le député
effectivement vous le savez une
ordonnance a été publié à l'issue de la
loi croissance et activités et surtout
de l'important travail réalisé par la
commission spécialisée du conseil
national de la transition écologique
ce texte constitue une véritable
innovation démocratique qui crée un
nouveau dispositif de consultations
locales et donc il y aura une première
application avec la consultation sur le
projet de transfert de l'aéroport de
nantes atlantique sur le site de notre
dame des landes
ce décret vous le rappeliez monsieur le
député de convocation des électeurs a
été publié le 25 avril
les élections auront lieu donc le 26
juin il concernera les électeurs du
département de loire-atlantique qui
correspond exactement au territoire
couvert par l' enquête publique dont il
a été fait objet dans ce projet les
électeurs seront donc appelés à se
prononcer par oui ou par non sur le
projet de transfert de l'aéroport qui a
été déclarée d'utilité publique en 2008
comme le premier ministre l'a spécifié
au président de la cndp par un courrier
publié la semaine dernière
cette ordonnance prévoit également qu il
y a un dossier d'information sur le
projet qui sera établi par la commission
nationale du débat public s'agit là
évidemment d'un gage important sur
l'impartialité la qualité de
l'information
ce dossier présentera de façon claire et
objectifs
les motifs les caractéristiques l'état
d'avancement des procédures les impacts
sur l'environnement et les autres effets
qui sont attendus en conclusion monsieur
le député nous invitons toutes les
forces démocratiques du pays à se
mobiliser pour cette consultation
du 26 juin si ce sera un moment de
vérité sur le projet c'est la volonté du
gouvernement afin de sortir par le haut
d'une situation de blocage qui n'a que
trop duré merci la séance des questions
au gouvernement et terminer la séance
est suspendue